so WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange was
interviewed on Fox News by Sean Hannity
and he used very very basic semantic
games which led to widespread headlines
that Assange confirms Russia didn't hack
the American election now I'm gonna play
a clip for you here and before we even
get to the clip
notice how Hannity is in super friendly
mode with Assange hannity has like many
hosts i mean i do this as well hannity
has one noticeable demeanor for friendly
guests and another noticeable demeanor
for hostile guests
i don't think that this is this is a
rare thing and even though Assange was
not a guy that the american right wing
wing liked for a very long time all of a
sudden now that he's out there saying
russia didn't hack the election which
helped trump win he's buddy-buddy with
people like sean hannity let's take a
look at the clip and what i want you to
focus on is the specific language used
here by julian assange for his denial
that russia hacked the american election
cyber criminals with the political
agenda of influencing the election and
obviously they're talking not just about
the john podesta emails the DNC emails
but in other ways I've asked you before
I'll ask you again today did Russia give
you this information or anybody
associated with Russia our source is not
a state party so the answer for our
interactions is no did anybody else
notice what I noticed our source is not
a state party the answer for here we go
now our interactions is know all that
Julian Assange has asserted here Pat is
that the people WikiLeaks was directly
in contact with were not official
representatives of the Russian
government
this denies nothing yeah and just in
terms of how sean hannity is treating
him yeah
six years ago he accused Assange of
waging war against the United States for
putting American lives in jeopardy
yo it just goes to the idea that Hannity
is willing to agree with whoever is in
charge of the Republican establishment
and at this time it's Donald Trump well
we know that Hannity has an interest in
disconnecting Russia from the hacking
that led to a favorable or well I would
say a favorable situation for Trump
because it was bad for Hillary Clinton
Hannity doesn't want Trump's presidency
to be deluged as it would be if we were
to confirm beyond a reasonable doubt
that Russia was involved in the hacking
but this is a semantic game this is a
game based on the specific words that
Julian Assange is saying and this
statement from Assange and I believe him
we don't even need to say he's lying
let's say it's true the source for
WikiLeaks was not a member of a Russian
state party and that and we can say that
that's absolutely true that tells us
nothing about whether Russia was at the
root of the hacking and it tells us
nothing about whether Russia influences
the election as the FBI and CIA say that
Russia did do even Sarah Palin yesterday
apologized to Julian Assange for
condemning him in the past everything is
backwards now Russia's not bad
Republicans like Julian Assange we're
living in bizarro world where up is down
down is up you say hello when you leave
and goodbye when you arrived Seinfeld
fans will recognize that I don't think
Assange is good or bad I think that that
that sort of man aquellas thick black
and white thinking is not what's right
here I think he has his own agenda yeah
and I think these Fox News hosts aren't
really standing on principle and if they
are they're principle is just to back
whoever's in power particularly if
that's a Republican yes yeah no doubt
about that so bogus interview watch the
entire thing if you can stomach it I
guess I could I ended up ducking out a
few minutes before the end thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated